Speaker 1: Let's go to Jimmy from Rochester.
Jimmy, you're on the air.
Hey, David.
Hello.
Speaker 5: Hey, you can hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 5: Cool.
So.
Speaker 4: Lately, I've been.
Speaker 5: Thinking a lot about how a person's
ethical philosophy kind of informs their political
stances on things, and especially how difficult
it is to argue with someone who doesn't share
your ethical philosophy.
Sure.
So, for example.
A like a libertarian would say that you should
never course anyone, basically.
And so if you don't agree with that like that's
why they.
Don't want to be taxed and that type of thing.
Speaker 1: Well, let me if I can jump in.
I don't know that I necessarily agree with
so with liberty.
I think libertarians and non libertarians
alike would often agree that coercion is bad
at a government level.
The disagreement comes in what counts as coercion
for me that in in your particular example,
that seems to be the greater dividing line.
Speaker 5: Sure, sure, sure.
And so even to take even a more obvious example,
like the the growth of like the Trump is the
Trump ism in the country.
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 4: If it how can you.
Speaker 5: It seems as as if it's not that
we both want to get the country to the same
place, but we have different ideas on how
to get there.
It's like we want to get it to completely
different places.
Speaker 2: Correct.
Speaker 5: So what do you do with that?
You know what I mean?
Like, how do you how can you debate someone
or argue or persuade someone when it's that
different?
Speaker 1: On individual issues sometimes
what you're so you are 100% correct that the
30,000 foot vision for the United States of
America is very different for a Trumpist than
a Social Democrat.
You're completely correct.
But sometimes at the issue level, the end
goal is the same.
So like, for example, you find a lot to pick
just to pick something.
If you think about abortion, many people on
the left agree they would love to reduce the
number of abortions, and people on the right
say that they want the number to be zero.
The difference is the people on the left would
say, well, let's reduce abortions by making
contraception widely available, teaching comprehensive
sex education, making sure women know that
if they do have a kid, they're going to be
able to afford all of the associated costs,
whereas the right says, let's, let's ban it
and make people ashamed for even thinking
of it.
So that's an example where even though the
vision is different, if we can find some similarity
in the end goal, then we can engage as to
how we most effectively get there.
So some so I think maybe what I'm saying is
while you're correct that the vision is very
different in different political factions,
there might be some overlap in the end goals
with enough people on the right that we could
have some productive conversations.
Speaker 5: That would be nice.
Speaker 1: It's a little bit pie in the sky,
but at least it's a it's an optimistic perspective,
I guess.
Speaker 5: Sure.
I mean, yeah, it's.
You have to start somewhere, I suppose.
Speaker 1: Yeah, exactly.
Well.
I appreciate it.
All right.
Thanks so much for the call.
Great to hear from you